let's have a threesome with your boy
Lucas wait or Noah Cyrus and Tana mojo
dating well that's what fans are
speculating so maybe we'll leave it at
maybes after the 21 year olds most
recent YouTube video was titled I took
my girlfriend's phone and flirted with
my best friend prank
here's how it all went down and Anna did
take Noah stop sending messages to their
pal Amar'e to see if he would ultimately
flirt back and the amount of times
Noah's called Tammis [ __ ] and Amar'e a
homewrecker
that's sparking those romance rumors
once again but it's Noah setting the
record straight posting to her Instagram
stories on Wednesday guys we are friends
relax
tannaz husband Jake Paul addressed Noah
Antanas relationship to ET back in
September so I think Noah's wanting to
hook up with Tana yeah because you know
even since the start of a relationship
which is why again I think it's funny
that like Nikita gets all Nikita dragon
gets all but her online it's like since
the start of our relationship it's been
like an open type of thing because
that's just like how we both are and I
think Noah and Tanner like wanting to
hook up and like be and know is the one
like pushing that pushing that narrative
which I think it's dope again and so you
guys didn't have an open relationship
then yeah for Noah and Anna
yeah you said goddamn call me jakey yeah
she called me jakey so you're God yeah
all right there in your story was more
like god damn good now right now my god
damn cause like damn girl okay all right
for you uh where - up there you have it